we're gonna get more cases no matter
what but we need to do with containment
and mitigation is too blunt that curve
on any given day you can't say oh we
blunted the numbers because the numbers
are still going up no matter what you do
it's how much up they go that is the
issue very sobering words from the
nation's top infectious disease expert
dr. Anthony foul a as the situation
continues to evolve quickly here and
around the globe one challenge is
keeping the numbers straight all of them
let's go to the Billboard as we like to
call it Bill Hemmer anchor of Bill
Hemmer reports hey heroes good afternoon
again I want to show you some of the
maps we put together on the map behind
me here from the World Health
Organization what viewers are about to
see is the state of the virus from three
weeks ago today and then we'll take you
through current time and we'll give you
an idea about the numbers based on what
we can report this is February 24th okay
three weeks ago Monday we highlighted
China Iran Italy in the United States
here in China three weeks ago you had
about 78,000 cases and Iran it was only
61 in Italy three weeks ago was 229 and
here in the US it was 53 now two weeks
ago today will change this map and show
you how they adjust about 80,000 in
China
look what's happens in Iran and Italy an
Iranian 2303 week prior was 61 so you
jumped to 2,300 Iran in Italy it was 229
now you're up around 2,000 cases I here
at home here at 64 up from 53 so a jump
of about 11 but again as you just heard
from dr. Falchi a moment ago Harris
these numbers are gonna change here in
the US once they start continued more
testing here now I want to take you two
weeks ago today so now we're on March
9th a week ago today I should say and
again you're right around 80,000 in
China so just just watch this part of
your screen here okay
two weeks ago 80,000 three weeks ago
you're at 77,000 so the numbers in China
have been somewhat consistent here
however in Iran look what you do here
you go up three times in Iran in Italy
from 9200 week prior or 2000 so again
that's about three and a half times in
the week prior in the u.s. from 64 53 to
64
cases here in the US now you come up
into today March 16th and again the
number around China is still about the
same but look what happens here in Iran
Harris you're 14,000 that that's double
from what was reported just a week ago
in Italy you're almost at 25,000 cases
today up from lots three times what you
were about a week ago and here at home
in the u.s. we're now at 1600 cases give
or take up from 472 of the week prior
now you can find different information
and you can find let me just shift here
to show you one more thing you can find
what we're trying to do is how we can
put all this information all these
numbers together so we're working the
World Health Organization we're working
with Johns Hopkins University in
Baltimore Maryland as well now what
they're doing is they're trying to
tabulate the numbers around the world
the deep red is the most severe cases
China over here in Iran Europe now big
concern and also here in the United
States so here's we're gonna watch this
and we'll take you through the numbers
as we tabulate them but again I want to
point out 106 75,000 confirm you have
77,000 recovered thus far Harris that's
very important when you think about the
White House briefing on Saturday of
those who were tested in South Korea 96%
have come back negative
yeah we hope for more of that yeah we
also hope for more of that other number
that I set off the top of this hour
those who've recovered
that's extremely yes as well no doubt
all of it
bill hemmer thank you a government
official is telling The Associated Press
the first participant and a clinical
trial for a potential coronavirus
vaccine or will receive an experimental
dose today however the Surgeon General
is cautioning we cannot count on that to
solve our current crisis watch what
people need to know is a vaccine is not
going to save the day at least this
first go-round the vaccine will be
helpful if we can get it developed
assuming coronavirus comes back again
next year in next season that of course
keeping with what many doctors have told
us like doc Siegel on the set here with
me that it's around just like the flu to
stay we'll see a to pharmaceutical come
he's confirmed they will soon begin
testing a drug used to treat rheumatoid
arthritis on patients with severe kovat
19 medical panel comes back now dr. mark
Segal six feet away from you here social
distancing onset
Nicole sapphire and Amy Compton Phillips
in Washington State great to have all
three years I want to go now to another
live if we can another live question so
we've got a lot of Technology working
for us this hour a Kathryn Barker long
in Marion Texas hello Katherine good to
see you I'm glad you're smiling what is
your question for the doctors yeah
thanks for taking my question finally
have been a small town Marion Texas it's
right outside of San Antonio and I've
only heard of three cases right now and
I'm wondering how the corona virus is so
much worse than the flu doc Segal would
you like to take that well you know
she's interesting cuz she's in San
Antonio Texas maybe there's more social
distancing there to begin with the
weather I feel may play a role but the
way it's worse than the flu is we don't
have a vaccine for it we don't have a
powerful antiviral treatment like we
have for the flu and we're seeing a
fairly large percentage of cases
especially in elderly people and people
with severe illnesses like heart disease
like severe lung disease like diabetes
these patients and cancer these patients
are getting very sick with this virus
and they develop a certain kind of viral
pneumonia that can be life-threatening
and we're seeing more people die right
now as far as we know
so the severe complications of this
virus are what bothers us you know one
thing that I like about your question
Katherine before we let you go is that
you're alluding to the fact that we
really haven't paid much attention to
the flu and it has killed a fair amount
of Americans this year as it does every
year thank you for your question from
Marian Texas
Jody P has a question she asks what is
the treatment for kovin 19 dr. Safire
well we don't actually have a known
treatment right now and that actually is
why a lot of people are worrying about
this a lot of Kanak going on with the
flu it's the same thing but we do have
an anti
viral that has been proven to work to
work for that there are actually
clinical trials right now for various
antivirals to see its effectiveness
against kovat 19:00 they're also testing
out utilizing antibodies from them those
people that have recovered to see if we
could instill that into currently active
infections to see if it helps and you
know everyone's kind of trying to get
various different things right now
there's HIV drugs of bola drugs and
various other drugs being utilized to
see if it potentially can help us get
through this pandemic alright dr.
Compton Phillips I'll come to you first
next round everybody sit by we are
seeing it across America Americans with
high anxiety about so many aspects of
covin 19:00 fear of the unknown is
driving people to stockpile food and
supplies some of them even fighting I
don't know if you saw some of that on
social media this weekend leaving
shelves at supermarkets and retailers
bare up next answers to your questions
about dealing with a psychological
aspect of the virus
[Music]